non je checke
alors que je venais de me faire attaquer
tout
doit la calomnie nord-est
alors des points déjà mathieu tu parle
pas comme ça avant d'associer merci
ces départs mathieu le jour où tu feras
le million sur ces huit ce qu'on a fait
est que jean pierre pernaut et de
documentaires qui exalte à mener alors
voilà déjà ce que tu sais pas et c'est
là où tu es mal il va y avoir une case
h2o de leurs mots production gasquet
parce qu'on est en train de créer une
société on voulait pas en parler
au moins deux choses et le biniou moi
j'ai fait plein de fois quand j'animais
11 fois avec la star ac' mapou était
même pas eu de débordement des la tum
admirons ceylan millions sur cette
chaîne un jeu signé
exactement
celui des millions sur cette chaîne
saos ma part comme vous l'avez deviné
production que sont ils devenus sur tf1
avant inside sur tf1 c'est normal de
faire le mignon paris bah oui batié sur
ses lecteurs de son ami sur ces vidéos
si tu fais pas mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'au dessus un
peu plus ou bien est ce que tu fais au
bureau mais tu es le seul gars qui a
fait 100 mille téléspectateurs
ça je ne vais pas le dire et là il a
produit là comme toujours
c'est le seul qui affiche 98 encore une
contre vérité parce que dans cette
émission on dit beaucoup de bêtises ça
ne travaille pas 131000
téléspectateurs 31 5 à plus de public
écoutez j'ai pas de répartie je vous
emmerde
restez pas du tout c'est peut être une
bonne journée mathieu non mais je vous
dis un après où sont fous de ça auquel
est calé alors je vais vous demander à
chacun quel est votre rêve ultime de
télé voilà quel est votre rêve ultime de
nous voir on finira par nous parce que
je voulais c'est vocale mais il aura une
très belle surprise pour vous dans un
instant bonjour me faire attraper de
tout ce que j'ai dit enfin et mais
surtout c'est vous qui m'avez attaqué
non banon 6,6 alors mais alors c'est pas
moi qui m'a attaqué n'ont
jamais arrêté votre enquête paranormale
tr je vais vous dire ça mais j'en ai
marre ça y est on dit ouyahia bonnes
joues demande des proches ou botté en
touche il hier pendant la pub j'ai pas
une petite preuve d'une petite case
machin vous avez tous là vous faites ça
que les yeux
je viens j'ai rien n'allait pas mais
n'importe quoi bingo
je sais vous la traque avec des boules
mais j'aime pas
j'ai une idée pour mathieu quoi est ce
que vous avez dit que vous n'allez
peut-être plus faire le truc de pâte à
modeler oui c'est vrai il pourrait
passer à la wii est génial c'est plus
long mais vrai un prime la pâte à
modeler parce que là là dans la pâte à
modeler au bon alors c'est pas sûr qu'on
le fasse plus court
est annoncée trop vite
beinheim la prochaine doit après la
fermeture
[Applaudissements]